i did everything to try to like not have
her be dead
um but i had no idea no idea what their
plans were
and um that's why for me
you know social media fans reactions
all of it is incred it becomes like
a collaboration you look like you've
just seen a ghost
you were dead senecan has become such a
fan favorite in the star wars universe
i know it's kind of a big question but
what does the role of phenix shand mean
to you
it means everything it means that
anything can happen if you really dream
it
it means um you know fulfilling
a lifelong fantasy of being
in this franchise i
you know as an actor and as a kid
growing up i
i i wanted so much to be in a star wars
project and
and i always wanted this in my life and
never thought it could happen
um so the fact that it has and that
as you said i love the word fan favorite
it's
it makes me so happy um
it's everything it's everything you know
and and now i can
walk around and go listen you have a
dream
go out and go and get it because
it can come true and it will come true
if you just
want it enough when you signed on for
the role or
when you got the role did you know how
expansive
it would go was there any indication
that it was like oh she's getting a
spin-off she's gonna be
in multiple shows like did you know any
of that at that point
oh gosh no and i i don't even think john
or dave knew
you know because in fact i was sort of
hesitant in the very very beginning
because i'm like
oh it's only one episode you know and
then she dies
and and i've been wanting to do star
wars for so long and it just broke my
heart
reading that and but then after talking
to john and dave i'm like you know what
this might be my only opportunity take
it girl grab it you know take a hold and
grab it
and so um
none of it i think it was just because
dave um and i he directed
gunslinger and thank goodness he did
because
we just hit it off and we you know had
such a rapport and um and then
on top of that uh we both found out that
we grew up in the same town
so and we went to the same high school
and
you know so if that took it over the
edge where he's like oh
wow now fennec can't die
i'll take it no that that was my next
question too because there was so much
you know when she died in that episode
there was so much disappointment
from fans of being like that cannot be
it i
refused to believe it i was like she's
not dead she's gonna come back she's
gonna come back
did you know when you were filming that
that she would be back or do you think
the reaction from the fans actually
propelled that
i think it's certainly certainly
propelled it
100 i mean we you know i would always
joke around with dave and john i'd be
like oh maybe you know
we could shoot a shot where her hand
twitches and just do a close-up of her
hand twitching and i mean
you know i did i did everything to try
to like not have her be dead
um but i had no idea no idea what their
plans were
and um that's why for me
you know social media fans reactions
all of it is is
incred it becomes like
a a a collaboration you know
and and i love that because coming from
theater that's what it's about it's
about
having that connection with the audience
and and and
whether you inspire them entertain them
you know the synergy is there
and i'm so grateful so so grateful for
all of it
did jon or dave just like call you up
and they're like guess what
she's coming back not only that gotta
pair up with boba fett
i know
so crazy right well you know um dave
told me that you know he wanted fennec
in
the bad badge and i'm like the bad badge
okay and yeah there was a different
there was another code name for that for
that
at the time but um you know it was a
younger fennec and he was telling me all
about he was getting really excited and
i was all excited
um so you know just
it's just all everything happened and
i'm just rock taking
taking taking it for a ride your bounty
hunter is fennec shand
she's new to the scene but has already
proven herself to be cunning and
ruthless
how would you say that the fennec that
we see in the bad batch is different
from the fennec we meet later on
in the mandalorian well she's 20 plus
years younger
so i think you know we had long talks
about it
to me if you're that young and and
you're trying to make a name for
yourself
you're just more ambitious maybe a
little bit more ruthless
more selfish and willing to do anything
and everything
to prove yourself so there's there's a
more
equality about her that's just a maybe a
little bit
uh less seasoned
you know more raw in her abilities than
than the
the fennec shan that we see in the
mandalorian especially in season two
um but how great to be paired up with
boba fett
i know oh my and that that post-credits
scene
from the mandalorian season two was such
a surprise that we were always
going nuts how was your experience
filming the book of boba fett fantastic
you know
i mean tim muera is such a gem of a
human being
first of all and you know such i mean
he's
had a legendary character for so many
years
and i love working with him i love
working with robert rodriguez he's you
know our showrunner
um and of course john and dave are
always there as well so
it's just a band of brothers and and i'm
one of the bros i think i just love it
i love them all so much and it it's fun
i mean every day i go on set on gaga
just gaga over all the toys all the
characters
that come through um tim's a little more
reserved about it he doesn't get as
geeked out as i do
so it's a nice ying and yang balance
between the two of us you know he reels
me back into reality
you see he i i can't even help it i'm
just like i geek out even talking to you
being like
like boba fett's alive yeah and you're
like his
bff like it's just right right
whether you know they both being bounty
hunters and
especially he's also the mandalorian
he's a mandalorian
there is a certain code you know that we
really do abide by
um and and i love that we honor that
and i i think because both of us have
experience
near death it that that
also kind of solidifies that bond we
have that to share it in common
and you know because i think when you
experience that you sort of feel like
you know maybe it is good to partner up
with someone
safety in numbers is there anything you
can tell us about
what the series will explore i mean
the exploration of their relationship
you know and
and what they hope to achieve so i think
i think what with their motivation and
their purposes we're exploring that
and um it's uh that's all i can tell you
it's coming out soon i know i i feel
like it's gonna be here before we know
but i can't wait
yes um one thing i definitely want to
bring up is you
are getting your star on the hollywood
walk
of fame it's so crazy what is happening
who
is whose life am i living right now i
don't understand
i mean i i never never in a million
years expected it my husband was the one
that was
like constantly saying that you know i
should
i should i've worked 40 years in this
business and i've done so much and
being an asian woman on top of it you
know
it's uh like all the obstacles and i'm
just like
okay whatever honey so um
you know he got my team to submit my
name and i
never in a million years thought i would
be chosen as
as a recipient i'm so honored and so
grateful for
the people at the you know hollywood
walk of fame um
it's beyond belief really it's beyond
belief
so well deserved congratulations i'm out
of time but
so amazing talking to you thank you so
much ashley and i'm so glad you love
fenney
i love that
you